since I'm only here for a
second I'll tell you a little story that
I haven't told anybody oh my God what
here
so it was
maybe
1983 84 or something there's a place in
New York City called Washington Square
Park anyone ever hear oh I just stayed
there for like I had a I rented a house
there that's a crazy place it's a crazy
place like you walk out of your house
and you're like what's good
I'm kidding I'm J J that can be a crazy
place so we used to break dance in yeah
I know that Park well and there was a h
a comedian named Charlie Barnett and
Charlie Barnett used to climb a tree and
say everybody it's
showtime and he'd draw the biggest
crowds and when he wanted to go have
Chinese food for lunch he would let us
ENT entertain the crowd with break
dancing and one day he brought this
little kid the skinny little kid and he
said this little skinny kid is going to
be a great comic
someday and we were jealous because they
made so much money and the way you the
way you kind of assessed how much money
you would make is the pile of coins that
you had and whenever the comedians did
the shows they'd have cash and we only
had coins basically and this young
comedian for the first time this guy had
introduced him to New York was Dave
Chappelle are you
serious that's how far that goes back
wow have you ever talked to him about
that I've never seen him again oh my
gosh this is the craziest story
yeah no it's it's bizarre I'm I'm only
I'm only saying that now cuz I would you
know I don't even think about the p as
much as I'd like to as we should all
reflect more about the past is because
Kelly is doing such a marvelous job of
taking me by asking me to do things like
what's your swag
walk that's going to make me thinking
about Dian Sawyer right there that's
some diany we going yo who's
[Music]
good
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home